wanna be happy live a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some of the best
motivation
from oprah winfrey enjoy
i always understood that there really
was no difference between me and the
audience
at times i might have had better shoes
but at the core
the core of of what really matters
that we are the same you know how i know
that because
all of us are seeking the same thing
you're here at this fabulous school
and will go out into the world and each
pursue
based upon what you believe your talents
are
what your skills are maybe your gifts
are
but you're seeking the same thing
everybody wants to fulfill
the highest truest expression
of yourself as a human being
that's what you're looking for the
highest
truest expression of yourself
as a human being and because i
understand that i understand that if
you're working in a bakery
and that's where you want to be and that
may be that maybe what you always wanted
to do is to bake
pies for people or bake cakes for people
or to offer your gift
then then that's that's for you and
there's no difference between you and me
except that's how that's your platform
that's your show every day so my
understanding of that
has allowed me to you know everyone to
reach everyone
and there's no way that you wouldn't
because that's that's what i
truly feel the way through the challenge
is to get still and ask yourself what is
the next
right move not think about oh i got all
of this
what is the next right move and then
from that space
make the next right move and the next
right move
and not to be overwhelmed by it because
you know your life is bigger than that
one moment
you know you're not defined by what
somebody says
is a failure for you because failure is
just there to point you in a different
direction
nothing about my life is lucky
nothing a lot of grace
a lot of blessings a lot of
divine order but i don't believe in luck
for me luck is preparation meeting the
moment of opportunity
there is no luck without you being
prepared
to handle that moment of opportunity
and so what i would say for myself is is
that
because of my hand in a hand and a force
greater than my own
i have been prepared in ways that i
didn't even know i was being prepared
for and the truth is for me
and for every person
every single thing that has ever
happened in your life
is preparing you for the moment that is
to come
you don't have to hold yourself hostage
to who you used to be
or anything you ever used to do because
who has lived and hasn't made mistakes
when i think about my 20s and what a
foolish girl i was
and how i would give over my power
to men who really didn't mean me well
but now i hold no grudges against them
either because i realized i'm the one
who gave over the power
because i didn't know any better and now
that i know better
i know i don't have to do that again
it's
one of the most powerful lessons any of
us
can ever know if i leave you with
nothing else it's just know this for
sure
there is not one thing
that has ever happened to you
not one experience not one encounter
not one crisis not one joyful thing
that hasn't happened just
to make you better and help you rise
every single thing you're calling in
whether you know it or not when you
figure out
that you are calling it in when you
actually start meditating or praying
or doing or having a spiritual practice
which is the number one thing you need
if you want to be successful in the
world you need something
that gives back and nourishes you
regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill
your cup so that you can be so full
your cup run is over and you have enough
to give to other people
if you don't fill your cup you end up
dried up
you end up tired exhausted and don't
have enough to give to other people you
end up resentful every time somebody
asks you
because your cup is empty and now they
want some of yours
so your number one job your number one
job is to fill your
cup and make yourself whole
also if you want to have more confidence
and learn from billionaires check out my
254 series they're free
the links are joined are in the
description below they
think that success
is supposed to happen like that it was
very difficult for me to figure out
where my boundaries were because
i'd grown up poor and didn't have
anything and now that i know better
i know i don't have to do that again
it's
one of the most powerful lessons any of
us
can ever know i think in order to
actually
do the stuff yes money is important but
i also think
the thing that i hold the dearest and
the reason why
uh uh the noise about running for
president
moved me so uh
humbly and deeply is because it means
that you have somewhere in the work
gain the people's trust yes and there is
nothing
more important to me than having the
trust
of the people and the audience and i i
mean i recognize that it is
the audience who came every day and
watched you know from
all over the world that actually yes
that that that helped me to be who i am
so
i think the uh the the renowned the the
standing
the the ability to be trusted and to say
something but also
listen don't play the billionaire thing
small don't play the beast mall yeah
it's
it's it's a very big deal because it
allows you
to it allows you to
it allows you to actually do the work so
instead of saying
gee i would like to help so many people
or you should go out and help so many
people
you can actually use that for yourself
and i am now
at this stage of my career thinking
about
how to do that more poignantly and
fruitfully
i'm now looking for ways that i can do
that to
uh create a level of sustainability in
within our community
so for me the foundational base of
empowerment of entrepreneurship
of any kind of engagement the
foundational
base of my success of my well-being
my wholeness my everything
is knowing who i am and where
i come from
[Music]
in my living room right now is a
painting that i've owned now for 30
years
you can google it it's called to the
highest
bidder and it's at the center of my
house
and it's at the center of my house
because it actually is symbolic
of the foundation of not the house but
the foundation for my life
the painting is by harry rosalind who
was a genre painter painter
in the uh early 20th late 19th century
and the painting is over six feet tall
and it shows a slave woman
on the auction block holding her
daughter's
hand and i cannot come in the door
my front door or i cannot leave without
passing that painting i am reminded of
where i come from
every day of my life and i am reminded
because i never want to forget it
and in my library i have a framed list
of enslaved african-american people
remember i showed you
who were held in bondage on various
plantations
listed in the ledgers alongside the cows
and the horses and the buggies and the
other property
and i pass this list every day and often
i stop in front of it and just
speak their names out loud
and their ages jonas
11 years old 500
sarah 41 years old
900. elizabeth
57 800
and i forced myself to consider the
absurdity
and the obscenity of prices being
affixed to each one
should they be placed up for sale
and i sometimes just pause before them
with a prayer
particularly before i have to make a big
decision about
one of my companies or whether i move
forward or whether i stay still
it reminds me speaking those names out
loud
not only of where i've come from but how
far
i have to go because of them and it
reminds me
that i am never alone it reminds me of
what i've
come through to get through everybody is
feeding yourself on the hysteria and the
negativity
you've got to stay in the light but one
of the reasons why i was so excited
is about a wrinkle in time because the
message is
that the darkness is spreading so fast
these days you must become a warrior of
the light and the reason that's so
meaningful to me
is because that's how i've led my whole
life and
every moment in that film i just felt
like i'm just saying what i've
normally said it's true and and for
these
times the darkness is there to show you
your light
look at what has happened so if you put
the focus on
look at what happened with the darkness
that showed up in parkland
and the darkness that showed up on the
streets of ferguson and the darkness
that showed up in many many many many
many many homes
in chicago with shootings and uh
senseless murders
it brings out the best in people it
brings out the best and so that's what
it's there
we live on a planet where there is
darkness
and light i deeply believe is not that
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you what you do is already done
that moment in the color purple where
she says everything you ever tried to do
to me
where whoopi says that silly everything
you ever
everything you even try to do to me
already done to you
so the law the third law of motion in
physics says
that what you're putting out is coming
back
all the time regardless of whether you
know it or
acknowledge it or not one of the things
i tried to do all those years on the
oprah show
sometimes people were criticized me
because i felt that i didn't do enough
for race or racism but this is what i
always understood
that for me my role
and my goal in life is to open this
open people's hearts that's what i do is
i
i try to tell stories that allow people
to see themselves in the lives
of other people and for me it was always
more powerful and effective to do a show
for example
on single parents raising their children
and just on the panel of parents to have
a black father and to show the
photographs or images of that father
putting his child to bed and reading a
story at night
that to me is more powerful than doing a
story on let's talk about
uh fathers black fathers who are raising
their children
because the goal for me
is to show that we are all more like
than different and that
in in our humanity in our ability
to express our humanness we are the same
so when you see
a father putting his child to bed at
night and reading stories and that man
is black
and you know that's what your husband
does and that's what you do you
you feel a sense of connection and
humanity
everything you try to do is already done
so when i figured that out oh what i'm
putting
out is what's coming back let me get
real clear
about what it is i'm putting out real
clear
so i read a book about 1989 called seed
of the soul
and in that book gary zhukov talked
about the laws
of karma of the laws
of cause and effect the third law of
motion
and in that book he talked about how
intention your intention is
always one
with the law meaning before you even
think about a thing
you have an intention for the thing and
that the
intention is going to determine the
outcome
that's why the same people can go to the
same church service
and somebody walked down the aisle just
to be seen
to put some money in the
church and somebody else who just goes
and just has a little bit to offer
the intention with which you give
the intention with which you serve
determines the outcome so when i figured
that out
i went whoa i changed
everything i did on my show i called in
the producers and i said
from this day forward i will no longer
be speaking to the kkk
i will no longer be speaking to people
who are fighting each other in a way
that it is damaging to the character of
myself and other people who watch
from this day forward i am only going to
do
intentional television i say to the my
girls
all of the time that your real work
is to figure out where
your power base is and to work
on the alignment of your
personality your gifts that you have to
give
with the real reason why you're here
that's that's the number one thing you
have to do is to work on yourself
and to fill your self up
and keep your cup full keep yourself
full
now i used to be afraid of that i used
to be afraid particularly from people
who say oh she said she's still fella
she's so close herself and now i embrace
it
i i consider it a compliment that i am
full
of myself because you only when you're
full i'm full i'm overflowing my cup run
is over
i have so much i have so much to offer
and so much to give
and i am not afraid of honoring
myself you know it's miraculous when you
think about it
my intention in creating masterclass
came from
the understanding that everybody's story
is the same all stories are connected
and there is nothing that anyone who's
living on earth
has ever felt or known or experienced on
a soul level
that hasn't been felt or known or
experienced
by someone else one of the most
difficult things in life is feeling that
you are the only one you are the only
one who's traveled this path who's felt
this way
i had nowhere to go i was homeless at
the time i lost my family
next thing i know i'm in this car for
three years man i'm struggling
who's experienced such devastation or
joy or triumph or victory so for me
i define a master as someone
who has fully stepped in
and owned the full
progress and trajectory of their life
persistence pays off that's less than
one
but hearing stories told from the mouth
of people who know
how to live how to course correct
how to keep going how to never quit how
to
rejoice in the good times and have faith
in the bad those people are masters
anyone who can do that is a master
and their ability to share their stories
only helps the trajectory
of others who listen a lot of people
don't know their purpose and if you
don't know your purpose
your immediate goal is to figure that
out
because otherwise you're just wandering
around here so the moment you can figure
out what it is you're supposed to be
doing
the sooner you are able to get about the
business of doing that my life is fueled
by my being
and the being fuels the doing so i come
from a
centered place i come from a focused
place
i come from compassion
um it's just my nature i come from
a willingness to understand and to be
understood
right and i come from wanting to to
to connect i mean the secret of that
show for 25 years
is that people could see themselves in
me
all over the world they could see
themselves in me
and even as i became
more and more uh financially successful
which was a big surprise to me i was
like oh my god this is so
exciting um you mean you got more than
that thirty thousand i got more than
thirty thousand
by the time i was thirty so
so my but what i realized
is through the whole process because i'm
grounded
in my own self
that although i could have more shoes
my feet stayed on the ground although i
was wearing better shoes these are kind
of cute today too
so i could keep my feet on the ground
even though i could get more shoes
and i could understand i could
understand that it really was
because i was grounded i've i've done
the was
doing and continue to this day to do
the consciousness work i work at staying
awake
dear beautiful brown-skinned girl
[Music]
and i use the word beautiful because i
know that's never a word
you would call yourself i look into your
eyes and i see
the light and hope of myself
in this photo you're just about to turn
20 posing outside the television station
where you were recently hired as a
reporter
you look calm you look happy
but i know how scared you are if i could
say anything to you
it would be relax
[Music]
it's gonna be okay girl the reason why i
was number one for 25 years
is because i figured out early on there
is no story
anybody has ever heard that somebody
else hasn't experienced
nothing and i also figured out
um probably maybe the first or second
year
that all pain is the same
that a mother in somalia feels the same
way as a mother in seattle when she
loses her child
and the common denominator in the human
experience
is our emotions and our feelings and the
more
vulnerable and open you are willing to
be with your story
the more actual understanding you create
with other people
and the more powerful you become people
don't think less of you for sharing your
story
they thank more of you for having the
courage to share it
what would you say to your younger self
oh honey honey honey
oh baby girl
what the world has in store for you
first of all would be relax
it would be stop being afraid and it
would be
everything's going to be all right no
matter what you're going to be okay
what inspired me was um an is
continues to be what continues to
inspire me
is a primal and fundamental desire
to fulfill the highest expression
of myself as a human being
i don't want to die
not having completely
burnt out every single possibility
of my humanity i just i just want to
when when i leave this planet i want
everybody did that
used it all up not another thing i could
do there wasn't another person i could
have given
of myself to there wasn't another deed i
could have done
there wasn't anything that you just want
you want to say i
want to fill it up you want to take this
whole human existence which when you
think about it godfrey is really pretty
damn miraculous it is it is it is when
you think about what it means to be a
human being on the planet earth right
now
that's pretty awesome so i just wanna i
wanna i wanna take that to the max
i wanna say no need to come back as a
human the day
first day i went to school i was in a
classroom
by the time i was uh you know six years
old didn't go to school i was six years
old because i lived my grandmother at
that time
but she had taught me how to read read
the bible bible stories
so i went into the classroom knowing
nicodemus
shadrach meshach and abednego i could
spell all of those words
i thought i was you know i was preaching
to the to my kindergarten teacher
so she was like who is this girl
so i was never placed in an environment
where i was ever made to feel inferior
i always felt like i'm the smartest kid
in this room
and because i was never placed in a but
never put in a position where i was made
to
feel less than i didn't grow up feeling
less than you know
and the rest as they say is history and
the rest they say is history
and it's all about what you believe you
know i say this to
uh when i i do something on my network
now called life class
the fundamental key to success
is what you believe is true for yourself
not what you want not what you desire is
what do you believe
you know you can say i wanted i want to
be the most successful person in the
world
but if you believe that there's a glass
ceiling and you're going to have a hard
time
kicking through that glass ceiling will
keep yourself you will be defined by the
glass ceiling
and um the great beauty and gift of my
life is that i was never
defined by the box that other people
tried to put me in
time this was early on you know because
when i first started making money
and it was you know my salary or my
earnings
were published all over the place i mean
the first year i was like really did i
make that much money oh my god
um it was very difficult for me to
figure out
where my boundaries were because
i'd grown up poor and didn't have
anything so it's easy when you don't
have anything and people ask you for
money
they say i need 500 you say i don't have
it because i'm just trying to get my
rent paid
it's harder when your multi-billion
dollar salary is now in the paper and
you get a
lot of friends and cousins you didn't
have before
so how do you set boundaries for
yourself i was having trouble setting
boundaries myself
for myself for even strangers people
would just show up at my door in chicago
and say oh bro i left my husband please
help me
and i would because she knows i haven't
so don't try that now though okay
don't try that now i figured it out
so what i learned was is that oh
the reason why people keep showing up is
because my intention is to make them
think that i'm such a nice person
that you can ask me for anything
you can get me to do anything i'm gonna
say yes i'm gonna say
yes so when stevie called me this time
i thought i'd try out my first no on
stevie let's start big
he wanted me to donate some money to a
charity and i didn't want to donate to
the charity
because i have my own charities and i
care about a lot of people but
the problem is when you you have money
everybody thinks you just want to give
to everything
so every letter i ever get starts with
we know you love the children
yes i do love the children but somebody
else is going to have to help the
children
so i said to stevie uh i said to stevie
no
and um as a person who has that disease
to please i was waiting for him then
just to say
i will never speak to you again
i will never call you i will never sing
a thong for you
and he didn't he just said okay
okay okay it's okay
he said okay check you later and
what i learned from that is many times
you will have angst and worry about
things
and put yourself in a state like someone
said
this morning because their phone went
off they were mortified over a phone i
said really
you will put yourself in a state when
the other person really isn't even
thinking about you
so learning that i could
specifically determine for myself
what the boundaries were for me
what i wanted to do give my money
give my time give of my service to who i
wanted to give it to
when i did that i get to make that
decision and just because you get 100
requests a week
doesn't mean you have to try to fulfill
all of that
just because you have all of these
demands on
your time and on you doesn't mean that
you
have to say yes you get to decide
because you're the master of your fate
the captain of your soul as william
ernest henley said
in invictus and understanding that
really changed the meaning of my life in
that
i was not no longer driven by what
other people wanted me to do but took
charge of my own destiny making choices
based upon
what do i feel is the next right
move for me turn your wounds
into wisdom you will be wounded many
times in your life
you'll make mistakes some people will
call them failures
but i have learned that failure is
really god's way of saying
excuse me you're moving in the wrong
direction
it's just an experience
just an experience just an
experience i remember being taken off
the air
in baltimore being told that i was no
longer be
being fit for television and that i
could not anchor the news because i used
to go out on the stories
and my own truth was even though i'm not
a weeper
i would cry for the people in the
stories and uh
which really wasn't very effective as a
news reporter to be covering a fire
and uh crying because the people lost
their house
um and it wasn't until
they i was demoted as a on-air anchor
woman
and thrown into the talk show arena to
get rid of me
that i allowed my own truth to come
through and the first day i was on the
air
doing my first talk show back in 1978 it
felt like breathing
which is what your true passion should
feel like it should be so
natural to you and so i took what had
been a mistake
what had been perceived as a failure
with my career
as an anchor woman in the news business
and turned it into a talk show
career that's done okay for me i was
interviewing a woman
uh on one of the shows it was so
impressive for me to see all the shows
that we've done lord made me tired
looking at it
but i was interviewing a woman it was a
show called
the mistress the wives meet the
mistresses or some
crazy thing and this woman was on
and it was a live show and in the middle
of it
her husband tells the wife and our
entire audience and the world
that his mistress was pregnant
yes to this day makes my eyes water
because
i saw his wife's face
and i felt her humiliation
and i said i will quit tv if i have to
do this i won't
do this anymore and my producer's like
what are we gonna do
this is what everybody's doing and then
that same
during that same time period so i said
i'm not going to do anything like that
anymore i'm not going to
not going to bring people on tv of
course we didn't know that moment was
going to happen they were like we didn't
know what was going to happen
but that should not happen on television
and i do not want to be a part
of the energy that caused somebody to
feel that because that's not going to
come back to me
i got to pay for that then i was
interviewing the
kkk on stage that was the day the one
guy called me a monkey in the audience
and during commercial break i could see
them signaling each other
and just watching them and their
behavior
i thought oh they get it i don't get it
they are using me they are using this
platform
because they understand because i'm
thinking oh i'm going to tell you all
about the kkk
they were using it to recruit members
for themselves
they were using it to recruit their base
and i then went to the producers and
said we're not doing a show like that so
they said
you're not gonna do the mistresses you
know
you're not gonna do it okay what are we
gonna do
so i said we we are going to
um create a baseline for ourselves
that's based on
intention this was around 1989 when i'd
read gary zhukov's book
called the seat of the soul and that
book was life-changing for me
because in it he talked about the power
of intention
and that cause and effect
what goes out comes back is determined
by your intention the energy of your
intention
is what determines your life most people
don't think about their intention they
just think about what they want to do
most people don't think about why they
want to do it but what's going to come
back to you the energy that's going to
come back to you
is the real why of why you did it
and so i then said to my producers we're
not going to do any shows that are not
intentional
so don't bring me an idea unless you
have an intention
for the show that you want the outcome
to be and we're going to
strive to see if we can live up to
our intentions and so around the late
80s we started
a pre-show to talk about what the
intention was and then a post-show
after every single show to say
did we fulfill that intention and that's
about the time i realized
this is bigger than me i actually
miss i miss you guys yeah i don't i miss
you guys
because where i got fed every day was
the audience
and i did not miss a day in
25 years because of the audience i don't
care how badly i felt i don't care
what kind of coal what kind of flu i
would come because
i knew that you know our ira in our
audience every day were
a couple hundred 350 people every day
who have literally told their aunts
their cousins they came with their
mothers they came
with their friends and i know that the
preparation to get there you've been
coming from iowa we've been coming from
tennessee
for days so it's not just a oh i'm just
going to oprah's show you tell that girl
i'm going to open it
and this is the thing i think i have to
just say please
everybody is feeding yourself on
the hysteria and the negativity you
gotta stay
in the light but one of the reasons why
i was so excited is about a wrinkle in
time because the message
is that the darkness is spreading so
fast
these days you must become a warrior of
the light
and the reason that's so meaningful to
me is because that's how i've led my
whole life
and every moment in that film i just
felt like i'm just saying what i've
normally said it's true and and for
these
times the darkness is there to show you
your light
look at what has happened so if you put
the focus on
look at what happened with the darkness
that showed up in parkland
and the darkness that showed up on the
streets of ferguson the darkness that
showed up
in many many many many many many homes
in chicago with shootings and
uh senseless murders it brings out the
best in people
it brings out the best and so that's
what it's there we live
on a planet where there is darkness and
light
i teach them that there is no life
without
cultivating a spiritual life because you
are
first and foremost a spiritual being
having a human experience and if you
lose sight of that
it's easy to get lost in the world and
no one can save a world that they're
lost in
when they've lost sight of their own
north star so having a spiritual life
actually means actively and ritually
creating the space in your life all the
time
for gratitude for kindness for empathy
for inspiration for joy and for
reverence for life
in the home of your soul first
and then working to spread that inner
joy
outward it means slowing down
it means taking in the moment it means
being exactly
where you are not distracted
somewhere else it means knowing who you
are
and getting about the business of
fulfilling
why you really came to our plan
what drives you to keep working so hard
you could you know you and i are
in the 60s category and so when you're
in your 60s you know you've lived more
than you're going to live
realistically so when you realize you've
lived more than you're going to live you
can say why not
relax a little bit why not just ease up
why have you decided to even work harder
than you did before
because i think david that everybody you
know the thing that works for me
all these years whether it was the
magazine or
which i still have or whether it was
the show i could i understood that
there's a common denominator in the
human experience
and i want the same thing you want which
is the same thing you want and you want
what we all want
is to be able to live out
the truest highest expression of
ourselves
as a human being that doesn't end until
you take your last breath
what is the truest highest vision that
you hold for yourself
no matter where you are in your life
there's always the next level there's
always the next level
to the last breath so i feel that i
always
knew that i would get be done with the
show when i felt like
oh i've said as much as i could say here
on this platform and then how will i be
used if
there were if there were a theme song to
my life amazing grace would be one of
them
and keep on using me to use me up would
be another one
you know that bill with her song
so i feel that until you have used
your value as a human being you're not
done create
the highest grandest vision
possible for your life because
you become what you believe when i was a
little girl
mississippi growing up on the farm only
buckwheat is a role model
watching my grandmother boil clothes in
a big iron pot
through the screen door because we
didn't have a washing machine and made
everything we had
i watched her and realized somehow
inside myself and the spirit of myself
that although this was segregated
mississippi
and i was colored and
female that my life could be bigger
greater than what i saw i remember being
four or five years old i certainly
couldn't articulate it but it was a
feeling
and a feeling that i allowed myself to
follow
i allowed myself to follow because if
you were to ask me what is the secret to
my success
it is because i understand that there is
a power greater than myself
that rules my life
[Applause]
and in life in life
if you can be still long enough in in
all of your endeavors
the good times the hard times to connect
yourself
to the source i call it god you can call
it whatever you want to the force
nature allah the power if you can
connect yourself to the source
and allow the energy that is your
personality
your life force to be connected to the
greater force
anything is possible for you
i am proof of that i think that my life
the fact that i was
born where i was born in the time that i
was and have been able to do what i've
done
speaks to the possibility not that i am
special
but that it could be done what i learned
going to beauty salon and asking them
after the news director had told me that
my hair was too thick and my
eyes were too far apart and i needed a
makeover and um
sitting in a beauty salon in a french
beauty salon
allowing them to put a french perm on my
black hair
and having the perm burn through my
cerebral cortex
and not being the woman that i am now so
not having the courage to say
this is burning me
and coming out a week later bald and
having to go on the air
you learn a lot about yourself when
you're black and a woman and bald and
trying to be an anchor woman
you learn you learn you're not diana
ross
and that you're not barbara walters
trying to be i was at the time
i had a lot of lessons i remember going
on the air many times and uh
not reading my copy ahead of time and i
was on the air one night and
ran across the word b-a-r-b-a-d-o-s um
that may be barbados to you but it was
barbados to me that night
and telling the story as an anchor woman
about a vote
in abstentia california i thought it was
located near san francisco
and one of the worst one of the worst
this is one i broke out of my barber
shell because i'm sitting there crossing
my legs trying to talk like barbara be
like barbara
and uh i was reading a story about
someone with a
blaze attitude which
if i had gone to wellesley i would have
known it was blase
and i started to laugh at myself on the
air and broke through my barbara shell
and had decided on that day that
laughing was okay even though barbara
hadn't at that time
and it was through my series of mistakes
that i learned that i could be a better
oprah than i could be a better barber
and i allowed barbara to be the mentor
for me as she always has been and i
decided
then to try to pursue the idea of being
myself and i
am just thrilled that i get paid so much
every day for just
just being myself but it was a lesson
long in coming
recognizing that i had the instinct that
the inner voice
that told me that you need to try to
find a way
to answer to your own truth was the
voice i needed to be still and listen to
get this this is just remember this
because this will happen many times your
life
when people show you who they are
believe them the first time
not the 29th time
[Applause]
that's particularly good when it comes
to to men's situations
because when he doesn't call back the
first time
when you're mistreated the first time
when you see someone who shows you a
lack of integrity or dishonesty
the first time know that that will be
followed
by many many many other times that will
at some point in life come back to haunt
or hurt you
when people show you who they are
believe them
the first time live your life from a
point of view of truth and you will
live your life from truth and you will
survive
everything everything i believe even
death
you will survive everything if you can
live your life from a point of view of
truth
close your eyes for a moment will you
please
and breathe with me just close your eyes
and if you will
put your thumb to your middle finger
and gather your other fingers around and
let's feel
the vibration and pulse of your personal
energy
as you take three deep breaths with me
inhale
and as you exhale just feel
the vibration energy
blood pulsating through
your body through you and another inhale
and another inhale
ah and keep your eyes closed
and let's just think about
this day
this day that you have been graced
to breathe
in and out thousands of times
this day where many of those breaths
were taken for granted you just expected
the next one to come
but the truth is there's no guarantee
that the next one comes
this day how you started your day
what your thoughts were this morning
how you've carried yourself through this
day
how you've been allowed to have
encounters and experiences
some challenging some more life
enhancing
that push you forward another day
of being here on the planet earth
as a human being
let's just think about that after all
you've been through
in this day alone
and the many days and years passed
how you got here to this prestigious
esteemed university
the choices you made that have brought
you to
this day
open your heart
and quietly to yourself
say the only prayer that's ever needed
thank you
thank you
thank you
you're still here
and you get another chance this day
to do better and be better
another chance to become more of who
you were created
and what you were created to fulfill
thank you and the number one lesson i
could offer
you where your work is concerned is this
become so skilled
so vigilant so flat out fantastic
at what you do that your talent cannot
be dismissed you stop comparing yourself
to other people
you're only on this planet to be you
not someone else's imitation of you i
had to learn that the hard way on the
air
live anchoring the news one night
in my 20s when i first started
broadcasting
i was 19 moved to an anchor by the time
i was 20
and i was just pretending to be barbara
walker walters i was just
trying to talk like barbara act like
barbara hold my legs like barbara
and i was on the air and i hadn't read
the copy fully and i called
canada kanata and
i did that on the air i cracked myself
up because i thought barbara would never
call canada kanata and that little
breakthrough that little crack
that little moment that i stopped
pretending
allowed the real me to come through
your life journey is about learning to
become more of who you are and
fulfilling the highest
truest expression of yourself as a human
being
you are responsible for your
life and if you're sitting around
waiting on somebody to save you
to fix you to even help you
you are wasting your time because only
you
have the power to take responsibility
to move your life forward and the sooner
you get that
the sooner your life gets into gear what
matters
is now this moment and your willingness
to see this moment for what it is accept
it
forgive the past take responsibility
and move forward actually i did this at
the end of my
uh show i did my
favorite guest of all times that's hard
to do out of
literally thousands and thousands they
supposedly estimated that there's like
35 000 people i interviewed over the
years but there was one woman
out of all the celebrities out of all of
the
famous non-famous infamous people one
woman who was she her name is
tarai trent listen to the story
i'm gonna try to shorten it for you guys
okay tara right trent
born and raised in a village in zimbabwe
11 years old she's doing her brother's
homework she wants to go to school her
father says no you're a girl
you have to educate the boyfriend yes
that's right that's right
the boy has to go to school you can't go
to school so she starts doing her
brother's homework
she does his brother's homework he goes
to school he gets all a's on his
homework yet he doesn't know the answer
to the question
the teacher comes to the village to say
what is going on here
this boy doesn't know the answers but
his homework's perfect she finds out
that
terrari his younger sister is doing his
homework she begs
the father to let tararai go to school
the father says no she can't go to
school
finally he marries her off she marries
at 11 and a half years old
she gets married she has three children
by the time she's 18 years old
a woman comes to the village from an ngo
heifer international and asks what are
your dreams this is going to make me cry
finally
ask her what are your dreams this child
has never thought about what her dreams
were
she says write down your dreams she
writes down her dreams on a piece of
paper and she folds them in a tin can
and she buries them
under a rock the first dream was to be
able to go to the school and
go to a school in the united states of
america
and get a college degree she ends up
through some miracle of the ngo
going to the united states she gets
a college degree wow yes she gets a
four-year degree in three years terror
right trend
she goes back to the rock in zimbabwe
she writes her next goal
on the piece of paper she buries it
under the rock
she writes i want to get a master's
degree
she goes back to uni and said she gets a
master's degree
by this time she now has five children
she's married to a man who still beats
her
incredible she goes back united states
she gets her master's degree
after the master's degree she goes back
to the rock in zimbabwe
she writes down her final goal is to get
a doctorate degree
and last year she became dr tararai
trent where did you find it where did i
find it um
i found her in the in the
nicholas kristoff's book called uh
something the sky underneath this guy or
this guy
and nick i found her in nicholas
christoph's book
and i was reading the story i had
nicolas christoph on the show nicholas
kristof the famous new york times
writer and
she wasn't there she wasn't a part of
the ch i'm reading the story i can't
believe this book the story of this
woman
as i'm reading the story so when we go
to do the show
the producers have nicholas kristoff on
they bring on other guests
but this woman isn't there i go how
could you not have her there
so we tape another show with nicholas
kristoff we go back and go
find we're gonna find that woman terror
right trent
this time by this time she's living in
the united states we followed
her back to zimbabwe to the rock
we pulled the tin can from underneath
the rock
and that is my favorite guest of all
time and the worst um
i don't have a worst i don't have a
worse but the reason why she and as i
said this on my show
the reason why terror right trent is my
favorite guest of all time
is because she represents in that one
story of the little girl in a village in
zimbabwe
who had a dream and the heart
and depth and discipline to pursue it
she represents
everything i tried to say in every show
in 25 years she literally through her
life story
sums up the message that i was trying to
give to every single one of my viewers
you can you can keep trying
don't give up the universe speaks to us
always
first in whispers
and a whisper usually in your life feels
like
that's odd or
that doesn't make any sense or
is that right it just really feels like
that it's that it's that kind of subtle
and if you don't pay attention to the
whisper
it gets louder and louder and louder and
i say it's like getting thumped upside
the head
you don't pay attention to that it's
like getting a brick upside your head
you don't pay attention to that the
brick wall falls down
that is the pattern that i see in
my life in so many other people's lives
and so i
ask people what are the whispers
what's whispering to you now i have paid
attention
to my life because i understand that my
life
just like your life is always speaking
to you
where you are in the language
with the people with the circumstances
and experiences
that you can understand and interpret if
you
are willing to see that
always life god
is speaking to you now
it took me a while to actually really
get this and to understand it but once i
did
i started paying attention to everything
and one of the reasons why i can now
accept the fact
that i can offer my
gatherings of information and wisdom and
call myself a spiritual teacher
is that every single person whoever came
on my show and i hear there's like
37 000 guests i've talked to
a lot of them came from dysfunction and
a lot of them wouldn't appear to be
teachers but every one of them had
something to say
that was meaningful and valuable and
that i could use
to grow myself into
the best of myself which is what all of
our jobs are
your number one job is to become more of
yourself
and to grow yourself into the best of
yourself
if you can find what is your passion if
you find what you love
you never get tired or if you do get
tired if you you're fueled by the energy
of your work
and you know what you're supposed to do
by how it feels
and so you know if you're doing the
right thing if it feels like it's right
to you and when you hit the thing that
feels right
you know it's right because it gives you
your juice
and you know it's right because you
would do it for nothing
you would do it for nothing and find a
way to be able just to do it
in order to be able to continue that's
how you know you're doing what you're
supposed to be doing
it is your job to make yourself
whole not perfect
but whole and full your world work in
life
your real work is to fill yourself
till your cup runneth over so that
you're never grasping and needy
clamoring and insecure but you can live
your life
assured in your worthiness and your
right to be here
and to become the best version of
yourself
as a woman being you came from very
modest circumstances you didn't come
from a wealthy family well modest is not
the word
well i was trying to be polite i was i
was actually
poor and i you know a lot of the girls
at my school actually all the girls from
my school
are poor and i was saying to them just
recently i was just in south africa for
graduation
you know you all are comf come from the
same circumstances you were poor
and one of the girls raised their hand
and said i don't like using that word
i go well if you're not poor then you
should excuse yourself because
that's why i'm paying for you because
you're in my school so if you're not but
you don't like the choice of the word
so i don't i don't have a problem with
the word i don't have any shame about it
i think
you know probably earlier in my life or
career
the word would have bothered me but it
truly it was it was i was poor
no running water david or electricity
living with an outhouse my biggest
frustration is not just with young women
my biggest
frustration is also with young men young
people
who think that and i have a lot of this
with my girls in college
they think that success
is supposed to happen like that yeah
they
think that there isn't a process
to it they think that they're supposed
to come out of college and have their
brand
and um i recognize now that i
am a brand but i was resistant to being
called a brand for many years because i
was like i'm
brand i'm not a brand i'm a person but
how i got to be a brand was not trying
to be a brand
how i got to be a brand was every day
making choices
that felt like this is the right move
now that's the right move and now that's
the next right move the next right move
and so my frustration with young women
and young men is that they think it's
supposed to
happen like this and they don't
understand that there's a process to it
social media yes social media you did
not get to be
editor of vogue magazine
by not working and working and working
and working and working to get here
i love the theory of that there's 10 000
hours behind anybody who ever gets to be
successful
who are your dream dinner companions
dead or alive
oh my gosh i would like jesus to come to
dinner and explain
explain is this what you wanted is this
really what you wanted did you want the
churches and the people
and the did you did you want all that
or were you looking for people to have a
different level of
consciousness does you want the christ
consciousness because i think a lot of
people got it wrong jesus
if you went opera what would you be
doing with your life i would definitely
definitely definitely be teaching in a
classroom
because it's the thing that still brings
me the greatest joy
um i now teach by satellite to my
uh girls in school in south africa
and it is my favorite moment
in the world when you can see someone
get it okay i know this is a short thing
but the other day i was teaching an
eighth grade class
and i was using my favorite quote from
maya angelou
where she says i come as one but i stand
as ten thousand wow that's a great one
isn't it a great one
great and i was saying to the girls
because sometimes they say sometimes you
know i feel so alone i miss my parents i
miss
because it's a boarding school i say
every time i walk into a room girls
i feel like maya angelou said when
she said i come as when i stand is ten
thousand
what does that mean close your eyes and
think of your parents
think of your mother and your father now
think of their mother and their father
not think of their mother and their
father and i did that for like a minute
to the girl started giggling i go that's
your ten thousand
so when you walk into a room you never
walk alone
you walk with the 10 000 who've come
before you
and are with you and are constantly
surrounding you
and i could see them get it yeah
which is just fantastic when the light
goes on
and you realize oh they got it the
beauty of my life
edward is that from i'd say
32 33 on i
figured out how to be myself completely
on television
and all these years i have
made a fortune really being myself so
i'm never not
me i'm never not the person that you see
you know there are days when i am
more open and warm than others and one
of the things that actually caused me
in 1991 to get my own
plane i was in the airport and i was
just minding my own business and a woman
came up and she said
you're not acting like you do on tv oh
and i said
what's that she says well on tv you're
hugging everybody and you're just
sitting here and you're not hugging away
i'm just sitting here man i'm just
waiting on the plane
so um if i'm in an airport i'm not
necessarily walking around hugging
people
okay but i am i am just
always just myself life has dreamed a
dream for you
and your your goal your number one
job is to figure out what that dream is
and
align yourself with the dream because
the dream cannot come to you
unless you're willing to meet it
energetically
in the same place so if your energy is
off
which i say to my girls all the time
they could teach this class right now
on being in flow if you are not in flow
with god's dream for you with life's
dream for you
if you are out of order if you are out
of sync
it cannot come to you it will not
come because the whole purpose of your
life
is to line yourself up with the purpose
and so if you are operating in fear
if you are operating in uh jealousy
jealousy will kill you when you are
synced up with life
life just gives to you it opens doors
it creates experiences it allows you to
meet people
things show up you never thought we're
gonna show up
and you are doing what
is the purpose of your soul being i
started the magazine
they said you will not see a profit for
at least the next five years and we were
profitable the first month the second
month and and and have been since
and so i thought oh okay those
predictions that is not really not true
i had no idea how difficult it would be
however i am really
um there's an old uh spiritual that says
wouldn't take nothing from a journey now
i really was speaking to stephen this
morning he was saying it's a good thing
that you went through that
because you were living on the
mountaintop for the past 25 years
you created this machine of the oprah
show that it just felt like
walking into okay here we go so no
struggle no
just it has become easy for me to do so
to be in a position to build from
scratch
this network and to go through everybody
thinking it was going to fail
and there were days when i had doubts
myself like
i had to force myself to actually
practice what i have preached for years
about going inside staying with the
vision
taking having every step move you in the
direction of the vision and trusting
trusting that building the right team it
was difficult for some days
one of the things i started to get uh
around mid
to late no no mid to late 90s
is that everybody that i had on the show
at the end of the show would say
something to me like
um was that okay was that okay
how was that was that okay at the end of
the interview
and i started to then track it it didn't
matter if it was
um i i i had gone and done a show where
i was in um
a prison i was interviewing a father who
was in jail for life for murdering his
twin daughters
and at the end of the interview even
behind bars he said to me
is that okay how'd i do and barack obama
said it when he sat in the chair the
first time
and george bush said it beyonce said it
at the end
of she taught me how to talk and then
said is that okay
so that's an acquired skill do they yes
working thing
but this is what i learned uh sitting in
that chair
for 25 years that at the end of the day
whether you are interviewing me
or i get to interview you whatever your
profession is
wherever you are in your life in your
relationships
every person that you encounter every
experience
the person wants to know was that okay
was that okay and what i started to hear
was that what people are really saying
is
did you hear me did you hear me and did
what i say
mean anything to you and so i
started to listen with that in mind with
that intention of validating that
your being here you're speaking to me
you're taking the time to do this with
me is important because you matter and
that's true
for everybody who's watching or
listening that every argument that you
ever have
every encounter the person just wants to
know did you hear me
did you see me and did i say anything
that mattered everybody has a different
talent
and the reason we're all so messed up is
because you're looking at everybody
else's talent
and wishing you had some of their talent
all the energy
that you spend thinking about wishing
about being jealous of
envious of anybody else is energy that
you're not only
putting out is going to come back to you
negatively but you're taking that away
from
you all your energy should be forced on
what do i have to offer what do i have
to give
how can i be used in service because dr
king's message of not everybody can be
famous
but everybody can be great because
greatness is determined by service
and there is not a job in here that you
can do
that you don't switch the paradigm to
service
and not make that job more fulfilling i
don't care what the job is
if you say i'm a singer i'm a dancer i'm
an artist i'm a teacher i'm a nurse
i'm a doctor i'm a janitor i'm a i'm a
clerk
if you say if i look at this from how do
i use
this in service to something bigger than
myself
it no longer becomes a job it becomes an
offering
to the world this is the beauty of of my
life there's not a thing that happens to
me
that i don't look at it as a
teaching learning experience and so
whenever i'm going into
any kind of crisis i've said this many
times before i'm always looking for what
is this here to teach me
reading is the strongest
signal for success in the future that
i've ever seen
it is the strongest strongest strongest
i got my first job in radio
uh when i was 16 years old because i've
been broadcasting since i was 16 years
old but my first job i got because i was
a great reader
when you are a great reader you can
articulate and speak
and command the english language in ways
that other people cannot
and people think you're a lot smarter
than you are lots of times
have you ever met a person who was a
great reader when they were young who
was not successful
you never never it is the absolute best
foundation
ever in life the first law is
the third law of motion in physics which
says
for every action there's equal and
opposite reaction
and we showed that very beautifully in
the color purple when
messily says to mister everything you
even try to do to me
is already done to you that is not just
a rhetorical saying
that is law that is newton's third law
of motion
in physics which says everything that
goes
out is coming back it's just like
everything that goes up is coming down
may take a long time to come down is
coming
down everything that goes out is coming
back
it's coming back so to answer the power
of manifestation and meditation
what meditation does is sync you up with
the source
what meditation does is allows you to
literally
tap into the power that created you
so that you are in alignment with that
and so when you carry that out into the
world
everything that you do comes from the
center of that alignment
that's coming from the source that we
call god we call divine energy divine
intelligence
whatever name you want to give it we
call life when you are synced up with
life life just gives to you when i first
started making money
i was one of those people who thought i
got it every time somebody asks me i
gotta ah
yeah so you go crazy you go crazy you
have to
look within yourself what do you want to
do that's that
that means family members because you
get a lot of cousins
wait a minute when you get the band
jones show all of a sudden you get
killed
so you decide for yourself and so i have
uh you know i've given away so
much that people don't know because most
of the time you don't hear about the
people
that i've helped so people complain
about what i did or didn't do
y'all don't know me i don't know you
don't know me i do
yeah i do and and god does so i don't
have
any let me let me get one more all of
that very much in check
lies in your personal intention
so it is my intention my
intention to fulfill
the dream of the creator
it is my intention to live to the
highest
calling and be pressed to the mark of
the highest calling
that i have come to do and when you can
ask the creator ask that
which made you you what is your
dream for me i guarantee you
instead of you trying to define the
dream what is your
dream for me if you're able to lean
into the dream that
the universe and all the forces of of
of of light and love and power
and grace by all the names that we call
god has for you nobody can touch you
nobody can touch you that show was on
for 25 years
in chicago and when you did it you won i
think almost 50
emmy awards and it was voted one of the
best tv shows in the history of tv
so you ended it though after 25 years to
do other things and we'll talk about
that but
no regrets about ending that show no no
we got no regrets whatsoever you know i
i didn't want
to be punch drunk in the ring still
trying to come up with what is the next
thing what is the next thing because
over the years we became our own
greatest competition
so when i first started went national in
1986
every time there would be another talk
should be oh geraldo rivera
what are we going to do and then i
realized a couple of years in
that you run your own race better than
anybody
if you take the time to see what
everybody else is doing you lose
your ground and that i could be a better
me than i could be anybody else and so
no need of trying to compare myself to
other people oh your own value
okay so when you're saying i know who i
am and i'm telling you it's the thread
that runs through
everything it's the thing that allows
you to stand in your own truth
and one of the things for years that
maya angelou used to say to me
is baby you need to know that you alone
are enough you alone
are enough every single day
i would have a pre-show meeting and have
the producers come in
and state to me what is your
intention how do we want to use
whoever is on this show whatever is
happening on this show
to serve the audience in a way that
fulfills the mission of uplifting
enlightening encouraging as well as
entertaining
and if it doesn't do that then i can't
do it i figured this out
early on in the show i had read this
quote from
dr king one of my favorite quotes from
him that says
not everybody can be famous but
everybody could be great
because greatness is determined by
service
and i literally shifted i used that
quote to help me
shift the way i saw the platform of
television instead of like
oh i'm on tv how do i use that platform
as a as a platform of services
amen this was what i did yeah yeah we
know and you did that pretty well too
but when you think about growing and
being empowered yourself it is
what you've been able to do for other
people
that that leaves you the fullest yes
that absolutely
there's a bigger dream waiting for you
just waiting for you to step into it
to step into it your life is big
your life is huge and we spend so much
time
wanting to be in somebody else's life
and you don't get honored you don't get
revered
you don't get celebrating wanting what
somebody else
has
because that which created you
divine intelligence that dreamed you
from before your ancestors ever knew
they would become your ancestors that
which
dreamed the seed of you
wants you to know how special how
wondrous how mysterious how complex
how glorious how phenomenal you are
and you get no credit messing in
somebody else's territory
or trying to have power
over something you have no control
another one of my favorite teachings
is the wizard of oz when the wicked
which is the west says go away from here
because you don't have any power here
you have no power in any territory other
than
your own oh but you
are the master of that you get to be the
master of your own fate you get to be
the captain of your
own soul and if you just manage that
if you just took care of your territory
all the glorious glorious glorious
wondrous wondrous opportunities
and possibilities that are waiting for
you so the question is
what are you resisting what are you
pushing against what are you not
allowing
what are you blocking because you have
this
idea of who and what you're supposed to
be
instead of leaning into the dream that's
already been created and waiting for you
it's waiting for you and the second i
mean it doesn't
it's an instant thing it's a shift
in the way you see yourself and the
power
from which you have come i started
feeling like i think everybody knows
i've i've moved my whole life on
instinct you know
i feel like now it's time to let the
show go i
feel like it's time to move on because
i've grown as much as i can grow when
i've grown as much as i can grow in a
space
that's my instinct to move i went
through some tough times
after after i left the oprah show i made
a conscious decision
that i did not want to be sitting on tv
with the oprah show and y'all saying she
should have left that show
that show was really good two years ago
i made a conscious decision decision
that when i felt i had said
all that i could say and the audience
had heard it that i would move on
and that i would not spend my life
regretting or trying to hold on to what
used to be or hold on to what i had
so i dreamed this dream of starting a
network
and in the beginning it was it was a
struggle
it was a struggle because i didn't
honestly the goodness i did not know
what i was doing
i was trying to figure it out i was
trying to figure it out
i thought that the oprah show audience
would follow us to own and then i
realized y'all didn't have cable
and if you had cable you did not have
the own package
[Applause]
so so it took me a minute and
unlike most people who you get to have
your mistakes in private
some don't go right in your life you get
to soak about it in private
if i make a mistake it's on the cnn
crawl
or the cnn news so when i was in the
climb and there were so many wonderful
owners i see churro action jackson here
there were so many wonderful owners
people who said oh we're going to stand
with you we're going to stand by you
thank you roland martin there were so
many people who said
listen we believe that this can happen
so i dreamed the dream
along with tyler perry who was my friend
who came to me and said tyler
tyler said i'm going to help you out
because tyler can go home and write a
script and
direct it produce it and shoot it
and do it for less money than anybody in
hollywood so we started with the
foundation
of having have not
if loving you is wrong
love thy neighbor mama hattie
and then i started to dream another
dream about
scripted television because in the
beginning i was told you couldn't do it
you couldn't do it didn't have enough
money to do it
and i dreamed the dream
i read proverbs 11 28 that says those
who trust in their riches will fall
but the righteous will rise and thrive
like a green leaf you can't get what you
want
by focusing on what you don't want this
is about the need to
establish as many meaningful connections
as we can
if we're going to save the world we have
to find a way
to connect to each other to connect to
the nature
that we're killing to animals to history
to an acknowledgement of the lingering
trauma of racism
and sexism we need to connect to the
people we love
and mean something to us and more than
that to the people who
don't that doesn't mean we always have
to agree with another person's
philosophy
it means we if we're going to continue
to survive
and thrive on this planet have to find
ways to transcend
the politics of division and embrace the
places that bond us
where we find our human ground and
everybody has their own dreams
there is there was a time where i used
to spend a lot of energy wanting things
wanting things of course it's easy for
me to say oh things don't define you
because i got a lot of things things are
nice i like them
but this is what i learned when you can
surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space that you
purposefully have come to earth to claim
for yourself
so around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning uh
sunday morning
should have been in church but i
wouldn't i was
reading the new york times review
of the color purple and i thought whoa
this sounds like a really great book
i got out of bed in my pajamas put on my
galoshes
and went to the store to get the copy of
the color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got
went back to the bookstore bought every
book of the color purple
i took the books to to the office and i
said to everybody y'all got to read this
book oh my god you got to read this book
color purple i needed a book club i
didn't have one
so i passed out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color purple
then i start to hear that somebody's
gonna do a movie about the color purple
but i don't know anybody in the movie
business by this time i was on am
chicago
i don't know anybody i start praying to
god god please help me find a way to get
into color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'll be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as as divine law would have it
quincy jones comes to chicago
and he is in chicago for one
half of a day because somebody has filed
a suit against michael jackson
claiming that billie jean was their
lover and that's not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago he was in his hotel room
he was coming out of the shower and the
television
in his hotel room is on am chicago
there sits little chubby me
with my jared curl
on am chicago quincy jones
tells ruben cannon the casting agent i
think i
found sophia so i get a call
from ruben cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song would you be
interested to come and audition and i
say i have not been praying for moon
song
[Applause]
[Music]
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well i think you should come and
and audition so i go to audition
you know movie people they make
everything all secret steven spielberg
didn't want anybody know he was doing
color purple so
on the outside of the script it says
moon song but i know
all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus
this is the color purple
yes
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part in the movie oh that
i'm thinking prayer prayer works
[Music]
prayer works but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february march april
may comes i haven't heard anything so i
call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon i'm sorry sir i haven't
heard anything i expected to hear
something by now and reuben cannon
african-american man says to me
you don't call me
i call you and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying i can't believe that god has
played this trick on me i think
this is a trick so i decide that this is
because
the fat has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose 25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i also was trying to make peace
with it i said god i don't understand
i thought it was for me you ever had
that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says
real actresses have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track at
the fat farm
it starts to rain y'all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god
to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life
i start praying running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i
i can't there's nobody on the track but
me and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
[Applause]
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
[Applause]
there's nobody on the track so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me help me let it go
help me let it go help me let it go god
help me let it go and you ever did this
prayer where you say okay lord don't
come and let it go then you get up and
you go well i think i still got a little
bit of it
i did help me let it go but i am not
going to be able to see the other
actress
in my part i won't be able to see it i
won't be able to see color purple
just can't never see it the rest of my
life i won't be able to see it
so then i started i don't know where it
came from
i surrender all
i surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
i surrender
all i sang and i cried i sang and i
cried and i prayed some more
until i could reach the point where not
only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress i can bless her
i can say i bless you
i bless you i bless you with this i
surrender all i
surrender all
thee my blessed
savior i
surrender all
and i tell you in my greatest
testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me
anymore it had no control over me
anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power
that was greater than i could ever know
the instant that happened a woman comes
running
out of the cafeteria
screaming oh free
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody could pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's saying named
spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir this is a health retreat
[Music]
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound you could lose
this part
no problem do i have
[Applause]
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said
you're hired you're hired please special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you going
to do
to take action on it this week when you
write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan
to take action on it this week let me
know put it down
in the comments below you build a legacy
not from one thing but from everything
i remember when i just opened my school
in 2007 i came back and i had the
great joy of sitting at my angelou's
table she hadn't been able to attend the
opening in south africa and i said to
her
oh maya the oprah winfrey leadership
academy that's going to be my greatest
legacy i remember she was standing at
the counter making biscuits and she
turned
she put the dough down and she looked at
me and she said
you have no idea what your legacy will
be
i said excuse me i just opened the
school and these girls and it's gonna be
and she said
you have no idea
what your legacy will be because your
legacy
is every life you touch
every life you trust
that changed me
[Music]
and it's true you can't personally stop
anybody from walking into a school with
an assault rifle
nor can you single-handedly ensure that
the rights that your mothers and your
grandmothers fought so hard for
will be preserved for the daughters that
you may someday have
and it'll take more than you alone to
pull 40 million americans out of poverty
but who will you be if you don't care
enough to try
and what mountains could we move i think
what gridlock
could we eradicate if we were to join
forces and work together in service of
something greater than ourselves
you know my deepest satisfaction and my
biggest
rewards have come from exactly that
pick a problem any problem
and do something about it because to
somebody
who's hurting something
is everything if you want to change your
life for free in the next 30 days check
the link right here below me or if you
want some success affirmations from
oprah check out the video right there
next to me i think you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
[Music]
there